hey everyone welcome to the channel now
whilst we are normally the heavy
spoilers show I thought I'd just take
time to do a spoiler free review of the
new Breaking Bad movie El Camino just
because there's a lot of secrets and
surprises that you may not want roon for
you I'm just gonna be giving my general
thoughts on the film and whether it's
worth checking out or if it ruins the
perfect ending that we got with season 5
now if that's all you clicked on this
video for to hear then you'll be pleased
to know that I thought it was great and
a really good extension of the original
storyline that flashes out Jesse's fate
with a satisfying conclusion without
ruining too much of the plot this movie
follows the aforementioned character as
he tries to escape a police hunt this
picks up immediately after the closing
moments of season 5 with the movie
opening with a flashback before going
straight into those seconds where jesse
was driving up the road to his apparent
freedom and boy does the film not let up
throughout there's a really tense
atmosphere to it all that had me on the
edge of my seat you really get the
feeling that jesse is in way over his
head and there are some incredibly close
calls even just very simple ones such as
a guy watering his plant that could
potentially spot him all of this
elevates it to crazy Heights at certain
points and it's arguably the most
nail-biting entry in the entire series
in addition to this there's some awesome
L cameos that really feel like a great
track down memory lane and a reminder of
just how good the show was whilst I
don't want to spoil these neat little
pop-ups let's just say they really got a
whole host of past actors from the show
to reprise their roles and watching them
return is some incredible fanservice
now whilst this probably wasn't
necessary entry and many people myself
included were worried that this could
potentially ruin the entire show by its
clothes I was so glad that they decided
to do it because it was well worth the
six-year weight and the 2-hour runtime
it can't be overstated just how good
aaron paul's depiction of Jesse Pinkman
is once more and he really really
delivers in
aspect portraying a truly broken man
with incredible ease mikhail perry era
which a hope of pronounced right summed
it up perfectly on my spoiler video by
saying that this is the dlc that makes
you beg for more and i really don't
think there's a more fitting comment for
the entire film there's very little to
fault here and if this is the last we
ever see of the character then I'm glad
we at least had one more chance to learn
of his fate and what really happened to
him after he was freed from captivity
somehow was some way Vince Gilligan
nailed the landing again and re cemented
Breaking Bad as one of the best shows of
all time Breaking Bad El Camino is
awesome and it gets in nine out of ten
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if you enjoyed
it as much as I did I've already put out
a spoiler talk on the movie in which I
go over the entire plot and give my
thoughts on it with the additions of all
the good bits that I can't talk about
here make sure you head over there if
you want to know more and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and if you want to come chat to me on
Twitter about movies TV shows comic
books and games and you can follow me at
definition whitey it's the best way to
keep up with the channel so hopefully I
see you over there
after this this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]
[Music]